um all right man well [__] hey before we
go can you give me the last time we hung
out you gave me
um
uh OG
uh burner in the in the uh
what do I forget what happened you
almost you're afraid you were gonna get
robbed in the mountains of Humble County
yeah that [__] went super viral let's
let's dive back 15 years 20 years burn
give me the another random just Story
Time with Burner give me a crazy story
about a situation that might have been
dicey back in the day
um it could have been in Humboldt County
it could have been in the Streets of San
Francisco give me give me a little
anecdotal little tidbit man before we go
well
I guess a good one would be um
I let someone handle something for me
one time and uh you know I just I felt
in my gut that wouldn't be the right
move I said bro like be a very attentive
these guys are kind of like
these guys are kind of Shifty and I
don't think they're gonna Rob You by
gunpoint but I feel like something's
gonna go wrong so you know I'm gonna let
you handle this because I'm not around
but like be very attentive to what
happens he's like bro for sure I got you
so he goes to meet up with this guy in
the hotel and
he gives them the bags in a duffel bag
and the guy gives them the money the
money is vacuum sealed and um you know
it looks right it's hundreds on top and
whatever and there was two vacuum seal
bags
and kind of made a joke like what you
don't trust me want to count here you
really want to count it all here like I
should do I got to move I gotta go box
these up and get them out of here and
just like yeah you know he's like bro at
least bust open one you can count it
real quick and you and the dude opened
up for him the vacuum seal bag and hand
him a stack and counted through a whole
stack it's all honest boom boom boom
cool put it back and he's like bro I
gotta go I gotta move you know I mean
boom my boy takes off can see where he's
going opens up the vacuum seals and the
rest of all the stacks are just 100 on
top of all ones oh and I'm like he calls
me and tells me like bro you really let
this man pull out the stacking counter
for you like I mean he didn't count it
for him but you really let him open that
pack up and he knew it was probably like
you let him give you the right corner
stack he didn't go through anything else
he's like bro he's moving so fast it was
nervous it was just seemed Shady he was
opening up the packs to start smiling
the room I just want to get out of there
with all that bread and I was worried
about getting robbed when I left on my
butt you're worried about getting robbed
when you left but you got robbed right
there he's calling to do his phones for
dudes phones or our services how much
how much money are we talking
I don't even remember at the time it was
like probably like 16 years ago or
something like that but I just know my
boy got [__] big time and it fell on
him I'm like bro you were there to
handle it you were there to count the
bread I told you what to do you didn't
do it so that's on you you gotta eat
that [__] hell yeah and you never
paid me back for it but yeah that was a
random one so and for all them bad boys
out there if someone comes with a neatly
stack of hundreds all flattened out
perfect in the vacuum so go through it
yeah you should never just take the
vacuum seal of money just open it up
make sure it's there it's actually I
mean you're already in the counterfeit
you're already somewhere doing a deal
it's I mean you already invested in this
situation counted out so you know that's
just a good old story that happened
someone pulled a slick one of my little
homie and while the homie is supposed to
pay me back but he did not the crazy
[__] is like right now in downtown L.A
it's it's it's the Wild Wild West like
if you're downtown and you live in a
high-rise I guarantee you there is a
Trapper on your floor and if you see
guys moving around with tons of luggage
all the time they're not traveling
is wild right now rappers stop shutting
out these these trap guys man let them
like let them build an organic following
them [__] it's crazy [__] snitching
dude dog it's like yeah it's crazy man
um well look man obviously uh people can
go I mean you got one's a New Mexico
opening uh November 3rd so November 3rd
that's coming new music coming collab
project with be real on the way Mozzy uh
oh Jeezy Mojo cookies clothing is going
crazier than ever yeah I feel like you
guys probably I mean
keeping Zoomies alive at this point
Zumiez has been a great party for us man
you guys are [__] front and center
yeah yeah they've been a great party we
got two uh shoes coming out next year
with somebody I'm not gonna say tennis
shoes yeah like sneakers are they fly
yeah
hmm
okay
I gotta keep coming with that you know I
keep coming with it man this is gonna be
a cookie sneaker coming yeah they try to
write me out man it's not happening I
love the slides yeah slides are good but
I'm talking about like a partnership
with a bigger company
like a collab sneaker a collab sneaker
yeah it's not just us putting out no
it's a collab with a pretty big brand
relevant brand and so why do you guys
stop doing denim or is it done you guys
not do it as much because you're a big
Jean guy yeah I mean I don't know that's
just tough focus on what you do business
yeah yeah focus on what works man well
look uh cookie shoes on the way so much
going on
um
oh real quick uh I know you're a big
Maui guy I had to be tough to see what
happened in Maui it's terrible that's
when I go to Maui I stay like that's
where I'm at I'm always in in Lahaina
eating food and you know I go to that
big ass tree and eat dough like yeah so
it's a it's a terrible situation shout
out to everyone on the ground putting in
that work out there in Maui a lot of
people are making sure that they're
taken care of I know that's kind of like
your like dream like if I retire yeah
you always talk about like going to Maui
yeah I mean I definitely want to be in
the Maui or Kauai but like yeah shout
out to everyone in Maui I've checked in
I've helped out you know I'm not gonna
I'm not one of those guys that publicly
just posts what I do for things but you
know I've helped out in the ways I can
and I know that there's good people on
the ground making sure people are good
out there for sure man well there it is
Big Burn I appreciate you brother
appreciate you bro yes sir yes sir boom